welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and i wonder if you will grant me 10
minutes of your time
to grace you with our latest breakdown
on the undoing
the puns are as bad as ever but we have
a lot to talk about this time
and episode 3 very much revolves around
us following grace as she tries to get
to the bottom of exactly what's going on
with her husband
the episode opens with jonathan being
escorted away by the police in the wake
of grace calling them
at the end of episode 2. it looks like
it's gonna be a pretty open and shut
case
as all fingers point towards him but i
think this entry does
a brilliant job of making us question
whether he's actually behind it or not
firstly the seed of doubt is planted
when the officers discuss with grace
how jonathan stuck his hands around her
throat and mouth last week
it very much comes across as if they're
under the belief that he tried to
strangle her last week
and it seems like grace even questions
this herself
however as we know from last time he was
simply doing it to stop her from
screaming
as he wanted to have some time to
explain himself this idea of us getting
one version of the events
and then the truth has very much been
laced throughout the show
and it further hammers home how there
are two sides to everything
it's been something that we've discussed
throughout all of our breakdowns
and a lot of you last week sent in
several comments saying that you think
grace is actually the one behind the
death of eleanor
this actually becomes more and more
likely throughout the entry and so far
the show has played heavily upon the
idea of duality
now it is indeed possible that grace has
dissociative personality disorder
and she committed the crime and then
repressed the memory in order to
continue living this perfect life that
she'd built for herself
the episode ends with her being caught
near the scene of the crime
and does seem to point towards her now
youtube user anna lims dropped a great
comment on our last video that discussed
how she may actually suffer from memory
blanks
and this is why her brain fills in
things with her own fantasies
this was shown when jonathan was in the
hospital and i believe it was happening
as the murder took place so it is indeed
possible that she was imagining this
in order to suppress the truth
jonathan's name badge also had a start
over the doctor part
and as we know the character was fired
from the position
this could hint that grace actually knew
this too but she has subconsciously
buried it in order to keep her mind
state level
anna also went on to say that it may in
fact be grace who inserted herself into
elena's life
and after she discovered her affair she
could have been triggered by her dark
side
grace's father seems to be very
protective over her which could
indicate her having mental health issues
the user also said that it's not
uncommon for people with mental health
problems to become therapists
as they know how important that
profession is so it does seem like
this is the way the show could be going
but i just feel that
as we're only halfway through it now
it's still a bit too early to be
dropping hints like this
however the intro of the series portrays
her as a child
gleefully playing and as we know she's
hallucinated elna at certain points
suggesting that she may have an altered
perception of the world
another theory is that it's in fact
grace's father who carried out the crime
in order to protect his daughter and we
do see in this episode that he is well
aware of where elena lived
however i can't see him being the type
of person that would kill eleanor
because in his eyes she would just be an
innocent woman
and instead i think that he would go
after jonathan himself
he has enough money to make things go
away and i doubt that
if he could get away with murder that he
would kill her mother
just to frame his son-in-law we discover
that jonathan actually went to him
and stated that he didn't really have
enough money to pay for their son
henry's education
and thus franklin gave him the 10 fees
however in hindsight we now know that
this was used to pay for eleanor's child
who was enrolled because jonathan pulled
some strings and paid for his education
now the scene in which franklin visits
elena's husband and the child
could be his guilty conscience but i
doubt that this is going to turn into a
hitman story or something along those
lines
and lastly out of the most obvious
candidates is jonathan
who you know what yeah i think he's
innocent
now in the book that the series is based
on a lot of the reveals that we've
already had such as jonathan's daughter
with eleanor
do come a fair bit later and it seems
like the show is deliberately dropping
these moments in early to let us know
that going forward
things will be different jonathan also
believes the point that he wouldn't take
a life
and as a doctor he's been sworn in under
a hippocratic oath
which means he won't bring home to
another human however we do see another
side to him in the entry
when he has a fight with an inmate and
he finds himself pinned on the ground
much like how the killer would have
pinned down eleanor jonathan brings a
whole new meaning to the phrase finger
looking good
and uh he bites the guy's finger now
also in this episode we're introduced to
a character named badger
who's a big attorney in the city badges
like to burrow in deep
and he was very much the character that
planted the idea of my head that
jonathan wasn't the one behind it
he questions him at one point and says
that he believes he is guilty but
later reveals to grace that he's
actually pretty sure about his innocence
they actually do a great job of making
us feel sorry for jonathan
as badger even says that he figures
jonathan is smart because he cures
cancer
the phrase the person who could cure
cancer is often used as a way to show
someone's importance
and it also carries the subtext that
whoever is doing this
is a good person thus the line brings a
lot with it
and whether it proves jonathan's
innocence or not it's clearly been put
here to suggest to us that he's a good
person who isn't behind the crime
now this idea of jonathan's innocence
burrowed in deep for me
and i love how this episode pretty much
has a lot of almost interrogation like
scenes
there's several points in which two
characters sit opposite each other
whilst one of them tries to get the
truth this is seen in badger and
jonathan
grace and badger grace and jonathan and
grace and her father
it really helps to play up the idea that
everyone is a suspect
and that we must question everything we
see as for the plot
the episode doesn't really advance it
that much but it does a great job of
placing the seeds of doubt in our minds
and it also makes us realize how
desperate grace is to keep her life
together
she pretty much forgives jonathan this
episode and almost lies to herself in
order to put him back on his pedestal
grace tells franklin that she just wants
the truth but it's unlikely that she
ever will actually get it
and she's had to live a lie in order to
have this perfect life
which shows that it's not really all
that perfect she goes to an ex-colleague
of jonathan's
and he tells her that he pretty much
flaunted his relationship with eleanor
and even thrived off the attention that
curing children's cancer gave him
it paints him out in a very different
light to what we've seen but grace
very much victim blames eleanor and says
that she was suffering from hero worship
this is a condition that involves you
becoming obsessed with the person that
you viewed as saving someone close to
you
but it also goes both ways now the
mention of hero worship
is ironic because grace herself somewhat
suffers from the condition
as she slowly starts to convince herself
of jonathan's innocence
not long after grace takes henry to see
jonathan and the conversation starts
with the latter saying
well another fine mess i've gotten you
into which is a play on laurel and hardy
a famous double act see see i told you
they like doing things in twos
jonathan admits to his affair and this
seems to tear henry apart
now there's also been theories that
henry could have been aware of his
father's affair
and that he was the one who followed him
to elena's and killed her
when the character went for a walk he
had access to jonathan's phone
and knew the password and was also not
at the school auction
so he did have the opportunity in
episode 1
both jonathan and grace did discuss how
he lived in a bubble
and it may be possible that similar to
grace he would do anything to keep this
from bursting
i highly doubt it's him but hey there's
only about five characters in the show
so
we have to go over all the theories
don't worry anyway grace ends up hiring
a new attorney named hayley fitzgerald
and going forward she will be the one
covering jonathan's case
she pretty much wants to muck it up as
much as possible i think it's going to
get ugly with eleanor's past coming to
the surface
i bet i bet you was all in all kinds of
dirty stuff mayor
blame the victims as i always say now
grace is eventually confronted by
elena's husband fernando
as she goes on one of her walks he
states that there were no other men
but does come across like he's hiding
something and
even wants her to be careful he could
indeed be behind it too
and we see through flashbacks that he
caught jonathan and his wife getting it
on
which does add to him having more motive
it really is up in the air over who it
could be at this point
which is definitely how you want to head
into the second half of the season
grace goes to the police to report him
for stalking her and this is when they
reveal that she was walking near to
where elena was murdered
now grace has gone on a lot of walks
throughout the season almost almost
about 15 minutes of the first episode
was her walking
so i i do think that they would be able
to excuse this
however it definitely does add towards a
dissociative personality disorder theory
and it is possible that she simply
blacked out all of the events that
happened
i kind of hope this isn't the case as i
think that's become
a bit too much of a cliche recently but
the clues are definitely there
either way this was another great
episode i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts and theories
on the show so far
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up make sure you check out our
breakdown of the finale of lovecraft
country which is going to be linked at
the end
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase 2
box set and all you have to do to be
with the chance of winning is like the
video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video you
been the best
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you